un nuevo virus que paralizó gran parte
del mundo
una crisis energética y la interrupción
del suministro de alimentos y los
efectos del cambio climático cada vez
más evidentes un nuevo grupo de
incertidumbres ha surgido por primera
vez en la historia de la humanidad según
Naciones Unidas
sí antes hemos tenido desastres antes
hemos tenido conflictos pero la
confluencia de lo que estamos afrontando
ahora es un gran revés para el
desarrollo humano el índice de
desarrollo humano del pnud que mide la
esperanza de vida los niveles de
educación y el nivel de vida descendió
durante dos años consecutivos un
retroceso sin precedentes en el progreso
humano visto en 9 de cada 10 países el
promedio de la esperanza de vida a nivel
mundial se redujo un año y medio entre
2019 y 2021 además de la perspectiva de
morir antes tener menos educación Y peor
situación económica la globalización la
polarización política y otras
transformaciones de la sociedad están
provocando un nuevo aumento del
sentimiento de inseguridad
lo más importante que tenemos que hacer
es volver a poner en el centro a las
personas y las decisiones que tomamos
Esto es lo que está en el corazón de una
creciente polarización una creciente
alienación extremismo y violencia
estamos viendo un desconfianza entre los
ciudadanos en sus instituciones y el
gobierno
las consecuencias de la invasión rusa de
Ucrania sobre la seguridad alimentaria y
energética no se calcularon en el último
índice lo que no deja lugar a dudas de
que las perspectivas para el próximo año
son sombrías